نقلت صحيفه عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان
مهاجمي خط نورد ستريم العام الماضي كانوا
على الارجح مواطنين من اوكرانيا او روسيا
او من البلدين معا ولم يشارك في العمليه
اي امريكيا او بريطاني وكشفت الصحيفه ان
واشنطن راجعت معلومات استخباراتيه جديده
تشير الى ان مجموعه مواليه لاوكرانيا نفذت
الهجوم على خطوط الانابيب ونقلت الصحيفه
عن مسؤولين قولهم انه ليس لديهم اي دليل
على تورط الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي او كبار
مساعديه في العمليه او ان الجناه كانوا
يتصرفون بتوجيههم من اي مسؤول حكومي
اوكراني
قال البيت الابيض ان واشنطن لن تستبق
التحقيقات التي يجريها الحلفاء الاوروبيين
الاوروبيون بشان تفجير خط نورد ستريم وقال
منسق للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي نواهنتون ما
تزال تنتظر انتهاء التحقيق الاوروبي بشان
تفجير الخط من جهه قلم ميلو بودالياك
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني انه لا علاقه
لبلاده بالهجوم على نورد ستريم ولا
معلومات لديها عن الضلعين في العمليات اما
نائب مندوب روسيا بالامم المتحده فقال
انما نشرت جونيور ساينس تؤكد صحه مطلب
روسيا بتحقيق دوليا في تفجير الخط